[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEON NICHOLLS: Hi, everyone.
My name is Leon
Nicholls, and I'm
a developer relations engineer
for the Google Assistant.
Today I'm going to introduce you
to several sample Actions that
are integrated with Dialogflow.
It's the fastest and easiest
way to create an Action
and to learn more about
the powerful features
of the Actions on
Google Platform.
We've added sample
Actions that allow
you to create working Actions
within just a few minutes.
You end up with source
code that you can easily
edit to add new features.
You can find these new samples
on our developer documentation
site.
You can select from
various types of Actions.
There are several
Actions that you
can use for daily updates
and notifications,
or be added to routines.
Other types include
simple adventure games,
interactive stories,
or a music player.
These are just to
help you get started
by giving you a Dialogflow
agent that is fully functional.
You can of course still create
a completely custom Action
on your own with Dialogflow.
You can preview the user
experience of each type
by playing the audio
recording of each Action.
Once you've selected the
Action you want to create,
click on that type.
Dialogflow will walk
you through a few steps
for building an agent that
will implement your Action.
Firstly, you'll be prompted
to give your new agent a name.
If you've used
Dialogflow before,
you can overwrite
an existing agent.
A Dialogflow agent is
created for you, including
all the intents, entities,
and fulfillment and code
to make the Action work.
Within just a few minutes, your
Action will be ready to use.
Your agent is preconfigured with
intents and working fulfillment
code that implement
our best practices.
You can then customize the agent
to make the Action your own.
To customize the agent, you
can update the source code
provided for fulfillment.
The fulfillment
is hosted for you
in a Cloud Function
for Firebase.
The source code has
step-by-step instructions
on how to customize the
Action, and provides links
to our docs on how to
extend the capabilities.
To try the action
the first time,
you don't have to
understand all the code.
You can come back later
if you want to customize
the Action even further.
Once you are ready,
click the Deploy button
to save your changes
to the Cloud Function.
Now you can test the Action in
the Actions console simulator
by clicking on the Integrations
menu in Dialogflow.
In the simulator, you
can test your Action
on different surface types,
like audio-only speakers
and mobile devices which have
audio and visual capabilities.
Once you are done
customizing and testing,
you can use the Actions
console to submit
your Action for review.
Once it's approved,
everybody will
be able to use your
Action anywhere the Google
Assistant is supported.
So that was a quick
introduction to sample Actions.
You can try them out
yourself by clicking
on the link in the
description below.
We also have a
Google+ community,
so you can ask your questions
and share your ideas with
everyone.
I'm Leon Nicholls.
Thanks for watching,
and I look forward
to trying out your Actions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]